The final type of optimization for
reducing the miss rate that we will look
at is a so called loop interchange which
is one of the compiler optimizations
that can be done to transform the code
into code that has better locality.
So suppose that we are initializing a
matrix like this by having an outer loop
and an inner loop and then we initialize
the element and then loop like this.
The layout of this matrix in memory
if it's a C array is such
that it begins with a[0][0].
The next element in memory
will be a[0][1], and so on.
Eventually we have the last
element of this row.
And only now we will have a[1][0] and
so on.
So now let's look at how this
loop accesses these elements.
i and j are both 0 at first.
So we will access this element.
Next, j will be incremented, so
we will access this element, and
then this element, and so on.
We will access all of the rows of
the matrix before we come back, and
start accessing the second
element in each row.
So the problem is, when this is
accessed, we fetch an entire cache
block worth of stuff into the cache
just to use this one element.
Then we're going to fetch a block
here to use this one element.
And by the time we reach
the end of the matrix and
look back here, we might have
run out of space in the cache.
And the block that we would now use
has been kicked out of the cache.
So we fetch it again,
use this one element, and so on.
So we have one miss per access here.
So a good compiler will detect
that the order of these loops
doesn't match the layout in memory and
it's going to perform what is called
a loop interchange which amounts
to simply sloping the two loops.
So now the inner loop is the one that
moves to the next element in memory.
So once we fetch a block from memory
we end up using the whole block.
Only then we move to the next block and
so on.
Once we are done with the row,
we move on to the next next row,
so now we are nicely sequentially
accessing this matrix.
Not only does it improve locality
because now we end up accessing
the entire cache block at the time,
but also it makes the access nicely
sequential so one of the prefetchers
can do a good job on it.
So this works really well, it
dramatically improves the hit rate that
we're getting, but
it is not always possible.
You cannot just take any two nested
loops and transform form them this way.
The compiler has to
prove that this code and
this code are equivalent, which it
does by proving that there are no
dependencies between
iterations of these loops.